I don't know if I would mind a little
hair like on the hips probably I just
think the actual cheeks if there were
hair on them the crack dude not the
cheeks like a man's it like an Italian
man's ass God damn dude like a [__]
Jewish Sideburn down there huh yeah
getting in her Jewish tunnels you see
them coming out of tunnels what
oh bring that up dude je it's been
they're getting some bad PR lately and
that's might be the worst one a guy came
out all right this is I swear to God I'm
not being anti-semitic a dude Jewish
dude coming out of a sore GR in New York
oh yeah def a video of that and it's a
New York synagogue erupted in a chaos
Monday night let's play a bit of it yeah
so I guess NYPD on Monday busted like a
secret meeting they I guess they had
been building secret tunnels underneath
through what the financial
system I mean this is worst case for the
Jewish people now not really not worse
yeah but not even the worst thing in the
last few but all right this is crazy
man they do get after it oh they're
crazy look at this one dude yeah they
get after it this one that popped out of
the floor right there poing out of
nowhere and he's D biggie walls look at
that D you see him don't flip the pews
Brothers oh they it's just hectic man do
you see how [__] comfortable that guy
was walking the plank yeah bro these
people they were fine with this or this
is orthodox jewi group man this incident
let me read the article so the incident
began Monday afternoon after a cement
truck was sent to the kabad luich world
headquarters known as the 770 due to its
address in Crown Heights according to uh
Co live the truck was ordered to fill up
an underground tunnel that had run from
the main synagogue to a now closed
building next door the outlet
reported first reports of the tunnel
surface in late 2023 after a homeowner
had called authorities about a
suspicious noises in his neighborhood
and that's drling isn't it I think I
mean think of hearing noises under your
house just Jewish guys it's just
somebody listening to modest
Yahoo like hey what's going on you can't
tell anyone you can't be like dude I
swear to God there's Jews under my
[__] house dude I know there's Jews
down there no one's going to believe you
yeah they're like dude you mean you need
to put down the [__] internet Jews
aren't everywhere like that you mean
underwriting your morgage or what are
you talking about they're like no
they're no they're [__] in there I
hear them they
whisper
however following excavation of a trench
for the project um simultaneously a
construction project was in progress to
install new Plumbing in the
770 um however following excavation the
underground tunnel had been discovered
the tunnel had reportedly been worked on
during nights for an unknown amount of
time stretching the tunnel to a next
door building women's section Ah that's
nice yeah meet me in the [__] tunnel
babe that's good that's crazy crazy dude
and that's Orthodox Jew is that Orthodox
Jewish people it appears so yes those
people are wild man we had a garbage man
on right and from New York and he said
the worst
people that he came across were Orthodox
Jewish people dude New York yeah he said
the kids would come out and tell him to
just go [__] himself and flip him off
dude they look at them getting rowdy
with the they were getting rowdy during
Co I think I heard maybe those tunnels
were so they could continue to go to
synagogue during during cuz they they
locked that down right now that's what
you know that's what the media is saying
well that right right by the media we
mean them so here's the guy coming out
of the grade look the guy coming out of
the grade is one of the most
anti-Semitic things I've ever seen in my
life dude oh
wow oh no where is this guy going dude
to get a rebate yeah that's insane
coming out of the Great bro they started
pepper spraying them and pepper spray is
not Kosher I don't think look it up
there's going to be some losses but no
we had a go we had a garbage man he said
that for some reason those people were
like kind of the coldest to him what did
he say Zach he he mentioned that the
kids would [__] with his truck and he
hated going there that was the main
thing and he also just said they were
rude and also was the new year they
throw all their [__] out every year oh
yeah that was part of it too I think so
there's probably some anger from him
because they had to pick up so much
stuff like they do like a cleansing I
guess I can say like it's part of
tradition to like reset everything when
the new year like everything out and buy
new so like that day of the year he
would they said they would just go up
and down the same street all goes
against some
stereotypes yeah you know that's true
yeah getting all new stuff man um but
they had this is this they had a group
in I don't know if it was in New York it
was like Orthodox Jewish people they
would move into a neighborhood bring the
value of the neighborhood down and
then um buy up the other places and then
bring it back
up there was some law uh it was like a
lawsuit that they
made or something um
anyway uh it's touchy subject but
there's no denying that there's tunnels
that is funny oh yeah it is there's
nothing we can do about you know we're
not trying to be oh I don't think we're
being bad people or anything because the
yeah these guys popped up out of a
[__] tunnel anybody
out yeah what the [__] were those guys
doing
tunel it's New York too like you don't
need everything's pretty close probably
just hunting square footage dude to be
honest that's a big
thing like this could be another six
square
feet